hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the dishwasher vampire
smile now weird name aside this is
actually a game that was brought back
from the Xbox 360 back in 2009 now I've
never played it before in my life but I
actually have heard of it the story
starts two years ago I'm not gonna do a
full playthrough of it but I am gonna
try this out for myself because you play
as I believe your dishwasher and
dishwasher is a Vampire Slayer I think
left mouse button to attack space to
jump e to grab left chip do P whoa and
it's a very smooth like 2d platforming
style fighting kill him beat him up
smash him the developer of this game
recently home oh my god get rekt haha oh
I thought you were dead hi-yah well
you're tougher than I thought you'd be
oh man enemies aren't just like get gone
enemies are like off oh yeah freak ha ha
ha oh oh oh oh hi okay who are you oh
okay I had no idea that I was gonna be
delving into this that bad then I woke
up
okay it's like there's pain get a numb
oh [ __ ] the rest was such a blur clothes
caked in my blood I had to escape I
stowed away in the first ship I found
and sailed with the moon from my window
I saw our earth erupt in flame things
happen fast from there I don't know what
you're talking about
they decided I was the culprit look at
me I'm on the news my fate was sealed
rod and jailer died on stage as it turns
out I would rot in jail okay I'm down
the if and Hasse space prison where
people like me go to die whatever
strengths I had is gone my sanity is
following there's no hope here and the
nightmares okay sleep isn't even an
escape though I'm so so tired oh this is
so weird oh this is so weird
man this threw me in it this so quickly
no idea
haha
[Music]
okay hi I'm crawling now I have no idea
what's happening but I'm so into it I am
so a hundred percent into this hello yes
please thank you oh I love the mix of 2d
art in the weird psychic like
psychedelic effects going on I can't
even think the words to describe it
oh man okay ah isn't it
oh my god I just got that wheelchair oh
hi
what what did I do
oh no am i a vampire I should step on
his body why did I do that I mean I
guess it's okay I guess oh hi stunned
enemies emit blue sparks we call that
sparking use your left mouse button to
mess up a sparking enemy oh okay
ah are you gonna spark for me yeah you
spark it on me holy [ __ ] oh man oh
my God my God my god oh I got hearts
I got hearts going on from that oh it's
so cool
whoa hi stop that I think what happened
he ripped his arm off looking barely
three that see through all the blood oh
yeah oh my god
I don't know what I pulled out of him
boy he needed it flap there goes his
arms Oh wolf a'dope clap clap
wait yeah I'm gonna grab you you're
tougher than wrestling not that much
tougher though oh man good Oh your dad
never got hearts though that's always
nice oh that guy didn't even have a
champions oh man this is like one finger
death punch all over him which I need to
do another video because I haven't done
that like years I used to play that just
as a regular stress reliever oh my god
I'm sorry this is so cool
then I gotta play the new oh okay okay
then I have a funny feeling this would
be easier to play on like a joystick or
something like that but oh my god it's
madness out there but there's a
perfectly good moon below me okay all
right let's find an escape pod okay
all right then whatever you say I'll
start by backtracking okay alright
whatever you say Oh backtracking you
said why is there why is there so much
traffic out there holy crap that's
awesome
I wish I knew what this world was all
about
oh god what was that
something about showing you wonderful
things I pass through that grape I feel
like my body was ripped into a mist of
blood chucked through space and hastily
thrown together what's happening to me
no you turning into a vampire you can
now use Yuki's blood war to use blood
warp tap left shift in the direction you
want to warp Yuki will home in on Emma
knees well worth it okay alright then
Yuki you go for it you keep your
defeated submit think so think so
sure oh that can't feel good that really
can't feel good oh no you shot that gun
oh hi you guys look marginally better at
this then oh well not that much better I
guess
for one BAM miss me oh it's the kickin
flurry as I pass over the floor oh oh
the thing that got ninjas guarding this
place white white what Nicholas I mean
again yeah it's cool stylistically what
was that guy about to stab himself why
was he doing that I was weird
I did marginally less good against those
guys but we'll see about what else I can
do about the rest of these [ __ ] oh
oh oh I did exactly what I shoulda done
whoa what are you
well not that tough barely
oh yeah floating skulls get shrekt you
badasses oh my god it's so cool ah
nothing else to say but oh [ __ ]
alright okay enough of that geez the
pile-driving these exploding skulls
maybe they should fill these skulls with
something other than explosives oh geez
where am I now
oh no valium right okay there's got to
be something else up here uh okay I know
it I got to I gotta walk up this wall
hi dad that's easy easy is that apparent
oh god whoa okay alright I can do that
it didn't know about that then what's
gonna happen when I actually oh you get
padre filed ripped okay thank you
ow ow don't do that gotcha
apparently got you also double combo on
that one
don't shoot me don't shoot me I'm
unarmed you're about to be unarmed but
I'm even more unarmed hello today the
dealer bug Gaylord dealer of the
crookedness justice I find whatever you
say
I deal with the dealer here
[Music]
he keeps dodging my crabs whoa hello Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam oh not quite mr. jailor
Gayler oh-oh-oh-oh
where's your head go where the [ __ ]
your head go Oh miss me man do you think
that these guys would give up and run
away or something because I have just
wrecking up there do I get a sword now
I think it's sword looks such a badass
oh sorry I need it need to stop freaking
out about everything I see oh boy how
about a boink boink you say oh boy
man they got to get tougher robots I'd
like to think that those are just
floating human heads in those things and
they're actually just blowing up in
horrible fashion Oh ninjas nah you're
just the guardsmen what are you gonna do
to me apparently you're gonna do a lot
because finally [ __ ] the other flap
hope and there you go
wow those spectacular
oh oh oh my god you can definitely combo
slicing him tossing him up the air doing
all sorts of stuff in that pile driving
them down into their destinies their
sparking alright
oh man got it I'm not even good at this
I will readily admit I'm not good at
this but I feel powerful I like to feel
more powerful than I would if I was
playing Devil May Cry or like God of War
I feel unbelievably powerful who are you
the warden if in house pain
administrator alright
sure let's go with that one well now
okay well I walked right into that one
I'm afraid to say ok you punch real okay
ah got something there I got hold it
wall one punch
alright let's try that again I went off
to a bad start I got kept running right
into your pouches alright come on bring
it on again you want this reminds me of
in a little way
the the aliens that it almost reminds me
of Alien Hominid in a strange way whoa
gotcha okay you're not too hard you're
not too tough cool yeah yeah Biscay oh
man
you you regret everything don't you hope
oh god those just the straight-up jabs
are bad for me Wow don't you dare oh you
don't you don't dare cuz you got nothing
Oh Oh what the hell cut off my arm
what'd you do that okay Oh everything is
clean here
why is everything clean here why is
everything okay well I'm in the clean
chair oh okay I'm in an escape pod
apparently oh [ __ ] yes one a 1-1
everything is clean here okay this
nightmare again what keeps bringing me
here who is taking my body over what I'm
here footsteps
I don't know oh hi okay all right that's
a hallway I'm not alone
who's there and what happened to my arm
well I know what happened oh hey hey now
how about you stay away I I don't need
that okay all right hello teeth are you
doing are you doing there oh good level
complete hey Tim pretty decent not great
mind you I'm not not one of the people
that are just amazing at this but I
could see you getting really good at
this game and it being so satisfying
like this game was so satisfying to play
it was so weird how just amazingly tied
it felt it just felt so bloody and gory
in such a simple package I loved it and
it was so noisy and grungy and grimdark
I loved it so anyway that's all the time
I got for this one I don't plan on doing
a full playthrough of this but maybe
it's just as a stress reliever I would
love to play this again because that is
frickin cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this down to comes flow and
I'll provide a link to it to steam in
the description as well thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]